[Musica]
questa immagine vi risulta familiare
immagino di sì pensate che ogni anno
passiamo più di 450 ore in macchina
l'equivalente di circa 20 giorni però se
vi può consolare vi posso dire che i
problemi legati alla mobilità non sono
nuovi della nostra era
anzi già nell'ottocento fine ottocento i
nostri antenati avevano problemi diversi
ma in realtà molto simili pensate che
nelle grandi metropoli dell'epoca come
londra e new york il cavallo era un
mezzo di trasporto più usato e gli
amministratori dell'epoca si trovarono a
dover risolvere il problema di come
smaltire le migliaia di tonnellate di
letame che venivano prodotte ogni giorno
e non ci fu una soluzione semplice anzi
non trovarono proprio una soluzione
pensate che a fine ottocento e tutti i
grandi urbanisti si riunirà la new york
però trovare una soluzione a questa
crisi è l'unica cosa che potevano dire
alla quella di dire bo le città non
potranno mai crescere al di sopra di un
milione d'abitanti altrimenti saremmo
letteralmente sommersi dalle camere cosa
stava succedendo per la nel frattempo
nel frattempo l'automobile veniva
inventato in europa e nel 1908 ford uscì
col a modelli chiara la prima macchina
adatta al mercato di massa
pensate voi che in soli quattro anni dal
1908 al 1912 in città come new york
c'erano più automobili che cavalli una
completa evoluzione nell'arco di quattro
anni che nessuno si immaginava dieci
anni prima
eppure stava succedendo stelo rocchi
perché vi parlo di questo vi parlo di
questo perché oggi ci troviamo in una
situazione molto simile quantomeno in
senso figurato
pensate che le arterie
di trasporto non sono più in grado di
rispondere al continuo aumento della
domanda e quindi il risultato è che ci
mettiamo sempre più tempo a spostarci da
un punto all'altro
una delle prime conseguenze
l'inquinamento con le automobili e le
loro emissioni di monossido di carbonio
che sono fra le principali cause
dell'effetto serra e grinder guarda
warning altra cosa ancora più grave è
che nessuno si sarebbe mai immaginato
all'inizio del novecento che
l'automobile sarebbe diventata una delle
più grandi cause di morte del ventesimo
e ventunesimo secolo
pensate voi che oggi ogni anno muoiono
più di un milione e duecentomila persone
sulle strade
questo è l'equivalente di un boeing 737
che si schianta al suolo ogni due ore
7 giorni su 7 365 giorni all'anno
però oggi come un secolo fa ci sono
nuove tecnologie all'orizzonte che
potrebbero permetterci di risolvere
questi problemi
nell'arco dei prossimi decenni come ad
esempio ai per look o i taxi volanti poi
ci sono altre tecnologie che sono molto
più vicino a noi che cambieranno
completamente il concetto di mobilità
nei prossimi 5 10 anni
e questo il caso dei veicoli guida
autonoma avere macchine che si guidano
da sole non è di per sé un'idea nuova
già negli anni 50 ci si pensava però
oggi per la prima volta nella storia
tutte le tecnologie che sono necessari a
farli funzionare
sono pronte hanno raggiunto allo stadio
di maturità
quindi vediamo un po di che tecnologie
parliamo innanzitutto un veicolo
autonomo per funzionare deve percepire
l'ambiente intorno all'asse a questo
viene fatto tramite un cosiddetto vision
systems vale a dire delle telecamere ti
cattura di immagini a 360 gradi e quindi
principalmente forme i colori
dopodiché abbiamo un altro sensore
chiamato leiber che ha il compito di
emettere un fascio laser invisibile a
360 gradi per andare a misurare con
molta precisione e la distanza la
profondità degli oggetti
poi abbiamo dei radar che vengono
tipicamente posizionati nelle estremità
del veicolo che vengono principalmente
usati per andare a calcolare la velocità
relativa di questi oggetti ed infine
altri sensori come microfoni che sono
utili per percepire suoni ad esempio
clacson o sirene da questo primo passo
una volta percepito l'ambiente intorno
il nostro veicolo devo andare a
classificare tutto quello che ha visto
quindi vale a dire quell'immagine che ho
visto davanti è un ciclista un
motociclista un pedone un cartello
stradale
insiema foro o cose del genere per fare
questo il nostro veicolo utilizza
intelligenza artificiale alle reti
neurali del veicolo vengono fatte vedere
centinaia di migliaia di immagini o di
tutte le diverse cose che potrebbe
vedere sulla strada di modo che poi le
posso andare a di conoscere in tempo
reale durante il tragitto una volta che
ha dato un nome a tutte le cose che ha
visto già forse la parte più difficile
vorrei dire il nostro veicolo deve
andare a prevedere il futuro e lo fa in
questo modo ha dato un nome a tutte le
cose
dopo di che deve andare a calcolare
tutte le possibili rotte tutti i
possibili movimenti che questo è già
andato a fare nel tempo e nello spazio e
sulla base del contesto andare a
prevedere quella che ha la più alta
probabilità sulla base di questo va a
calcolare la propria rotta e la esegue
dando comandi al volante acceleratore e
freno
pensate che tutto questo viene fatto
decine di volta secondo grazie al fatto
che abbiamo processori molto potenti
oggi disponibili che sono in grado di
elaborare questa questa mole immensa di
immagini che arriva dal sensore e non vi
sto parlando di fantascienza
mi sta parlando di una tecnologia che
esiste oggi è che stiamo già testando da
quasi un decennio soprattutto negli
stati uniti nelle strade pubbliche in
california in arizona principalmente non
vi nascondo che di lavoro da fare ce n'è
ancora parecchio c'è ancora parecchio
lavoro da fare per andare a rendere
questa tecnologia disponibile in sempre
più area provi posso anche dire che noi
ingegneri siamo molto spronati a cercare
di rendere questa tecnologia disponibile
al pubblico il prima possibile
soprattutto per andare a salvare delle
vite umane pensate che il 90 per cento
degli incidenti che accadono hanno
causato dall errore umano e con i nostri
veicoli autonomi
saremo in grado di portare in basso
decisamente questi numeri grazie al
fatto che prima di tutto come abbiamo
visto il nostro micro autonoma in grado
di vedere molto più distante e di
reagire molto più in fretta rispetto
umano e poi bisogna considerare che le
altre guida autonoma non si addormento
nella guida non si mettano a mandare
messaggi mentre guidiamo e poi nostro i
nostri computer sono pure astemi quindi
questo aiuta sempre
quindi questo questi vantaggi saranno
evidenti gianni un futuro prossimo
quando questi veicoli andranno a
condividere le strade con i veicoli di
corrente generazioni con i veicoli
manuali questi vantaggi saranno ancora
più evidenti in un futuro dove potremmo
immaginare che ci saranno strade dove
sarà permessa la circolazione solamente
veicoli autonomi e non è assurdo pensare
a questo perché pensate voi
oggi non possiamo andare a cavallo oa
piedi in autostrada
eppure un secolo fa nessuno se l'affare
va mai immaginata quindi immaginiamoci
il nostro bel futuro driverless siamo
nel nostro veicolo e non siamo costretti
a guardarci intorno
perché il veicolo seguito da solo e
quindi possiamo fare dell'altro
potremmo decidere di leggere un libro di
lavorare oppure diversi bicchieri di
vino
intanto il guidatore astemia e quindi
questo cosa porterebbe porterebbe al
fatto che dobbiamo fare un po di
attenzione
infatti se siamo così comodi sui veicoli
autonomi
potremmo essere incitati a prenderli più
spesso perché la fine una così pesante
spostarsi da un posto all'altro e quindi
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che il traffico
aumenterebbe invece che diminuire e cosa
facciamo quindi semplice costruiamo
delle altre strade forse no forse non è
un'idea così brillante infatti forse
dovremmo aver imparato qualcosa dal
secolo scorso
soprattutto negli anni 50 quando negli
stati uniti si costruivano delle città
che erano molto più a misura di macchina
che a misura d'uomo
e a questo giro possiamo fare meglio
questo giro possiamo fare sicuramente
meglio e possiamo pensare al fatto di
unire questa nuova innovazione
tecnologica le macchine guida autonoma
con i nuovi concetti di trasporto ad
esempio car pooling vale a dire mettere
più persone che si spostano da un punto
all'altro a bordo della stessa macchina
eliminando macchine della strada e
quindi diminuendo traffico
se noi riuscissimo in questo in questo
passaggio e sono riuscissimo a fare
questo
il lavoro di noi ingegneri e sarebbe
riuscito a fare quello che vogliamo fare
vale a dire rendere il trasporto molto
più sicuro rendere trasporto più
sostenibile restituirvi tempo di qualità
e ridurre lo spazio fra le città fra i
luoghi ma soprattutto tra le persone
grazie
[Applauso]